effet la lutte pour la troisième place
semble se jouer entre les listes du
modem de françois bayrou et celle de
daniel cohn bendit en tout cas la
tension est donc montée d'un cran je
vous le disais entre les deux hommes
hier soir sur france 2 lors de
l'émission d'arlette chabot et les
nuggets
ces deux-là faisait estrade commune pour
le oui au référendum en 2005
les voilà désormais concurrent daniel
cohn bendit a pris l'avantagé en étions
d'âge de quoi énerver françois bayrou
qu'il accuse de complicité avec nicolas
sarkozy
vous êtes venu déjeuner trois fois à
l'elysée en tant président avec tous les
présidents dont le président de ton vous
sentez-vous mal je me sens pas mal je
trouve ça ignoble de ta part
eh bien mon pote je te dis jamais tu
seras président de la république a bien
parce que t'es trop minable très bien
trop minable je ne suis pas sûr que vous
puissiez vous employer le mot ignominie
je trouve ignoble moi d'avoir poussé et
justifié des actes à l'égard des enfants
que je me place accepte sûrs que tu es
bien là dessus à l'allusion un livre
publié en 1975 par l'ancien leader de
mai 68 sur la sexualité des enfants
livre dont il avait déjà regretté la
teneur il ya huit ans peu après le débat
daniel cohn bendit a réagi il qu'on a je
crois qu'il a dépassé les limites il a
pété les plombs de ce pugilat il a
évidemment été question dans les
derniers meetings de campagne pour la
droite
françois bayrou a dérapé cette façon de
faire de la politique de la part de
françois bayrou mais coeur il a
totalement perdu son sang froid
or en politique un responsable de fait
serein à gauche c'est l'indignation
appel à tout le monde à la dignité des
débats
je crois que l'europe
mieux que des attaques personnelles moi
c'est pas ma conception de la politique
moi je n'ai qu'un adversaire c'est l'ump
n'ont pas les hommes et les femmes et
leurs idées je pense qu'il faut rester
jusqu'au bout de digne du combat qui est
le nôtre terne jusqu'ici la campagne
européenne vient en tout cas de se
réveiller
à quelques heures du vote